thank you so much for this honor  this is an incredibly proud moment for  all of us at ftrac  not least because the award comes with  the recognition of our peers  in an industry that we truly love and  are so proud to serve  bjorn matthias and i would like to  extend a huge thank you to the whole  f-track team every employee makes a  massive contribution to fx studio  and we value you all so much i would  also like to thank our families who have  supported us over the last decade  you kept us on track through all the  trials and tribulations of software  development  and finally of course i would like to  thank all of our customers  we're endlessly amazed by the work you  create and we're humble to be part of  the process  thank you again to the academy and to  everyone who helped make this moment  happen  we truly couldn't be happier thank you  very much  you